MALE SPEAKER: So, just by way
of introduction, I want to say,
I learned to play
Go many years ago.
When I learned to play Go,
I had received a Go board
as a Christmas present
from my parents.
I was I think 12 or 13.
There were no Go
players around me.
I taught myself to
play by reading books.
I taught my friends to play.
It was many years
before I played anyone
who I hadn't taught myself.
Later, when I graduated from
college, I came to the Bay Area
to play, at San Francisco Go
Club, among other places--
a fine representative of
that institution here--
and was always grateful.
In those days, there
was an AGA, I believe,
but there was no US Go Congress.
There were no
professionals that I'm
aware of living in the
United States at that time,
or anywhere in the West.
And so, since then, we
have US Go Congress,
which happens every year.
This year, it's in Boston,
sponsored by the AGA,
which is, as I said, Mr. Okun's
wonderful organization that he
leads.
They have a YouTube
channel as well,
and you can see streamed
Go commentary there.
The American Go Foundation
is the charitable arm
of that organization.
You can donate--
they're a 501c3.
Google will match that donation.
If you search the United
States Go Foundation,
you can find that I sponsor
the annual Google Giving
campaign for them.
So that's a great organization.
They teach kids in school
and spread the word about Go
in general.
And, as I said, the US Go
Congress is held every year.
It used to be that a
visiting professional was
a rare and wonderful event.
But every year now
they have this event,
there's 30 or more-- I don't
know how many we have confirmed
this year-- but 30 or more
professionals come from all
over Asia and now, the West.
So we now have actual Western--
the AGA has professionals
that they certify.
So having said
that, I would like
to welcome today's guest,
who's a professional player
from Korea.
Her name is Hajin Lee.
She is the general secretary
of the International Go
Foundation, which
is-- Foundation?
Federation?
AUDIENCE: Federation.
MALE SPEAKER:
Federation-- thank you--
which is an outreach group
sponsored by the Korean Baduk
Association.
And she is a professional
3 dan herself.
So let me switch
over to her slides,
and I'll hand it off to Hajin.
[APPLAUSE]
I can drive the
slides if you want.
HAJIN LEE: OK.
Ah, thank you.
Hello, everyone.
Nice to meet you.
Thank you for taking your
time to come here for my talk.
I'm very excited to talk
about professional Go players
and AlphaGo match today.
I hope you will
find it interesting.
So, to begin with, let me give
you a bit of my background.
As Lee mentioned, I'm a
professional Go player
from Korea.
In Korea, we call
Go, "baduk"-- so it's
Korea Baduk Association.
We call it KBA.
So I'm a professional
player with KBA,
and I became a
pro when I was 16.
The picture over here
on the right side
is me playing on the
best-of-three final match
for the major title for
female players in Korea.
I didn't manage to
win this final match,
but I was one of
the five Korean team
players for the international
team competitions,
and I won one minor title.
And I also won a bronze medal
in the first World Mind Sports
Games in Beijing.
And five years into my career
as a professional player,
I went to university.
Can I go?
Yeah.
Yes.
Sorry.
So my decision to
go to university
surprised many people around
me, especially my parents,
because at the time
of my application,
I was one of the top
players in Korea.
And going to university
meant a huge distraction
from pursuing the very top
place in the tournament world.
But in my mind, I always
wanted to see the world
outside Go tournaments.
And then I was
afraid that if I wait
for, like, one year, and
two years, and three years,
I might lose the courage
to start anything new.
So, at the time, I
was 20 years old,
and then I decided
to go to university.
I studied business
administration and specialized
in finance.
At first, I was afraid that I
would have a hard time catching
up with other students,
because in my whole life,
I only studied Go.
But it turned out, studying
in university was really fun.
I loved going to classes
and writing papers and doing
team projects.
And then I had a great time, and
I graduated as a valedictorian.
And in my last semester, I was
planning to go to grad school
to get a higher degree in
finance, because I enjoyed
being a student so much.
But at the time, coincidentally,
International Go Federation
was looking for a candidate
for the next general secretary.
They asked KBA, Korean
Baduk Association,
to recommend a candidate,
and then their requirement
was that they wanted someone,
a professional Go player,
with English ability and some
international experience.
And there I was, a
professional Go player,
graduating from
a university that
is teaching 100% in English.
And then, also as
a student, I was
working part-time with the KBA
as international coordinator.
So KBA interviewed a few
professional players,
and they decided to
recommend me as a candidate.
At first, the IGF board
was a little concerned,
because I was only half
the age of my predecessor.
And then, you know, I was just
graduating from university.
But they decided to honor
the KBA's recommendation.
And that's how I started at
the International Go federation
as secretary general, and
I'm still working there.
Being the youngest
ever secretary general
had many challenges.
But on the bright side,
because I was so young,
many of the board
members were more
willing to help me and guide me.
So I had a great mentor.
And then, I learned so
much by working at the IGF.
Some of them were good
things, but some of them
were, like, more of
the frustrating side
of international organizations.
But I'm very grateful
for the opportunity,
and then, I was just
very lucky, I think.
And while working at the
IGF, I did two things.
The first one was that I
started a YouTube channel.
And, at first, it was
just an experiment,
because there weren't
many strong players who
were doing the live
commentary, meaning,
like, you talk while you play.
And that format could be very
risky for professional players,
because basically, you're
giving away your secrets.
For professional
players, you need to win,
and then you don't want
to share what you are
thinking while you're playing.
But when I went to university,
I stopped playing in tournaments
actively, and I wanted to see
whether this kind of format
would be helpful
for amateur players.
And then I was going to
just post a few videos,
but it turned out, it was, a lot
more popular than I expected.
And then, as I was receiving
these messages, how,
like, my viewers improved a
lot by watching my videos,
I couldn't stop.
So it's been about 1 1/2
years, and I'm still doing it.
Today, I have over 150 videos,
7,000 subscribers, and close
to 10 million minutes watched.
Another thing is that I
published this book over here.
Some of you have seen it.
So, this book,
"Outside the Board,"
is a collection
of my blog entries
that I wrote from 2008 to 2013.
It's about that time
when I was still
an active professional player.
And then I stopped
writing my blog when
I started working at the IGF.
So my blog entries covered
my flashback stories
of my childhood--
how I studied Go,
how I became a professional
player, my life
as a professional player, and
my matches, my overseas trips,
my classes, the books I read.
It's very wide.
And then, I just selected
some of the interesting ones
for the book.
So that's about my
background, and then, I
would like to start with
professional Go players.
So, I am a
professional Go player.
And then, you're probably
familiar with Fan Hui and Lee
Sedol.
They are all
professional players.
So professional
players are the ones
who dedicated their life
to develop their Go skills.
I believe that
AlphaGo was the result
of the brilliant
developers of DeepMind,
but AlphaGo was also
possible because there
were professional players
who dedicated their lives.
Imagine-- if Monte
Carlo tree search
was strong enough to compete
with the top human players,
then I think they would have
thought of just improving
a little bit, instead of, like,
coming with this breakthrough
method to be even stronger.
So I believe the
DeepMind was inspired
by professional
players, and then they
knew that they needed
something different approach.
So, you know, you
probably heard why
Go is such a difficult
game for a computer
to learn-- the wide variations,
and so many branching factors.
And for the same reason, Go
is a difficult game for people
to be stronger as well.
And before I tell you more
about professional players,
I would like to share
this cartoon from xkcd.
This is about estimating
time for a project.
The first girl says,
ah, I have a hard time,
like, estimating the
time for a project.
And the second girl says,
I have a simple trick.
You first estimate some
time, and then you double it,
and then you double it for
the second time, and then
a third time.
And then, realize
that you are doing
this imaginary
calculation instead
of working on the project.
So this one seems like
it's just a goofy cartoon,
but it actually makes
a lot of sense to me
as a professional player.
Because this is the how I
feel about the necessary time
to become a professional player.
So imagine this--
there's this one student,
and she wants to be a
professional player.
And then I would
tell her, imagine
you are really ready to commit.
And then you are going to
study eight hours a day,
five days a week,
50 weeks a year.
After one year, you would
have put in about 2,000 hours,
right?
So starting from there, we are
going to double it-- 4,000--
and double it for the
second time-- 8,000--
and for the third time--
it's 16,000 hours.
So maybe after
about 16,000 hours,
you would have gotten close
to professional level.
But we will add some more
time, because getting
to the professional
level doesn't mean
you are a professional player.
Oh, and you should remember
that you might not ever
become a professional player,
because it's very competitive.
Wait.
So this is the time I put in to
become a professional player--
19,000 hours.
So, I started playing
when I was five years old.
And then, it was
very natural for me,
because both of my
parents liked to play.
So, at first, I learned
from my parents,
and then we would study
about one hour a day,
about four to five days a weak,
but with many missing days.
When I was six years old,
I won this small tournament
for preschoolers,
and then my teacher
thought I had some talent in Go.
So after that, we
increased the study hours,
and then we started
studying two hours a day.
And then I became
nine years old.
And at the time, my
parents and my teacher
thought I had a
really strong chance
of becoming a
professional player,
so I moved to a
Go master's place.
My Go master was
about close to Seoul,
and my hometown is not in
Seoul, so it was about two hours
distance by car.
And then, at the
time, it was very
important to get the proper
training with the Go master,
if you wanted to become
a professional player.
So I lived with the Go master,
his wife, and their children,
and a few other fellow
kids, just like me.
So when I joined the
Go master's place,
we would study pretty much
all day, other than the time
we go to the public school.
So I would study something
like from 2pm to 10pm
with a one-hour dinner break.
So that was about
seven hours a day.
And then when I
became 12 years old,
I joined this official
training program of the KBA.
It's widely known as "insei"--
that's a Japanese term.
In Korean, we call
it "yunguseng,"
or we can just say, Go prodigy.
So when I became yunguseng,
it was, like, really serious.
And then, I had a
lot fewer holidays.
And I would study
not until, like,
10 pm, but more like
11 or midnight, so that
became eight hours.
And also, if you
are a student, you
have summer vacations
and winter vacations.
In those days, you
don't go to school.
Then we would go to
the Go school at 9 am
and then study until 9pm.
So that's how I started.
And then when I added
up all the hours,
it came out 19,000 hours.
I became pro at 16.
So let me read you a small
part of my book over here.
"It was an endless repetition
of many types of training.
I played against peers,
received comments on those games
from the teacher, studied
professional players' games,
solved exercise programs,
and played again.
Moreover, I had to
memorize well-known games
of prestigious players'
games as homework.
While I was suffering the
tediously long study schedule,
all I could do to
entertain myself
was to chat with Yoo-Jin
when the teacher was absent
or to go out for ice cream
during short breaks."
This training is when
I was nine years old.
So it was very serious.
And then, you know,
it was serious,
not only because getting to the
professional level is so hard,
but also, the
competition is so tough.
If I told you that this was the
chance that you would succeed
at something, would you try?
[LAUGHTER]
So this number seems very
low, but it's very realistic.
The Korean Baduk
Association estimates
that there are about 8 million
Go players in the country,
and about 30% of
them are under 18.
So we can assume that there
are over 2 million youth
players in Korea.
And KBA selects 15 new
professional players each year.
And then, it's not
an absolute number--
it changes each year to reflect
the number of Go players,
but they never increase widely.
When I became pro in 2004,
they were selecting nine pros
a year.
So, in some years,
they select a few more,
but usually, it's
about that level.
And then, it's not like when you
get to the professional level,
you will become a pro,
but more like they
would organize the Pro
Qualification Tournament.
And then upfront,
they will say, we
are going to select two pros.
And then, it's open to
anyone who wants to compete.
So, like, 100 players would
enter the qualification,
and then the top
two players would
become professional players.
So that's why, even if you
get to the professional level,
you might not become a
professional player, ever.
Because some players
can get really nervous,
because it's such an
important tournament.
And then, if you don't
win in those tournaments,
then you have to compete again
the next time, the next time.
And then, as time passes,
you get a little older,
and then there are more
younger and talented players.
And the pressure is
just so enormous.
So that's why it's
very difficult.
And then, someone
did this study--
this study took the
recent-- about 50--
professional players in Korea,
and then saw when they started.
The average-- they started
at 5.3 years old, and then
they became pro at 17.6.
And then, studying
over eight hours a day
is usual practice in any of
the professional Go schools.
So you can imagine that this
is a very long and hard journey
to become a professional player.
Let me read you another
part of my book.
" 'I resign.
Congratulations.' She offered
her hand over the board
and shook mine lightly.
I couldn't see her
eyes nor say anything.
I fixed my eyes on the
board and remained silent.
Soon enough, she stood
up and left the room.
My heart was beating
so fast and loud
that it felt as if it
would explode any moment.
I closed my eyes.
I could not think of anything
else but repeating, 'I made it.
I am a pro now.' "
So, the day you become a
pro is like a birthday,
because you will live a
totally different life.
Once you become a professional
player, first of all,
you get out of that
pressure, that huge pressure,
that you have to pass the
Pro Qualification Tournament.
So it's a very emotional day.
And then you just remember
the day, I think, forever.
I still remember this scene
very vividly in my mind.
I stayed in the
room for a while,
and then I walked
out of the room.
And then my parents were
waiting, which was surprising.
I didn't know they were coming.
And then, with my parents
there, was this journalist
from "Baduk" magazine.
It's a monthly
magazine of the KBA.
"Baduk" magazine has
about 60 years of history,
and then they interview each and
every new professional player.
So the picture over here-- it
was clearly taken on the day
that I became pro.
And then, when I see this
magazine-- when I see myself
in the magazine--
then I really, really
realize that I made the cut.
So this was the
magazine, and then that's
how I became a
professional player.
So you did this long journey.
What does that mean, to
be a professional player?
I understand that
in English, usually,
"professional" means that
your living income is
coming from that work.
So, if you are
making life from Go,
then you're a
professional player.
Otherwise, you are not a
professional Go player.
But in Korea, it's
a little different.
And actually, not only in
Korea, but also in Japan,
or China, or some
other associations
with professional systems,
in Go, "professional"
means that you got this title.
It works more like a
degree than a status.
So it could be an
equivalent of a Ph.D. in Go.
So once you, like, test
this Pro Qualification,
you are a professional player.
It doesn't matter if you are
making money from playing
or not.
And then, when you become
a professional player,
people stop calling you by name.
Especially in Korea, they
don't call me, like, "Hajin,"
but they call me, like, an
equivalent of "Master"--
"Master Lee," like this.
So, like, my friend was
saying that you're a Jedi.
You're called "Master."
[LAUGHTER]
And also, in the
KBA, my IGF office
is inside the KBA building.
And then when there
are new staff members,
they are about my age.
And then, like, in
the first week or so,
they would call me "Hajin."
And then after a
month or so, they
learn to call me "Master,"
like all other senior managers,
because they do that to me.
So it's a very honorary title.
And all professional players
are eligible to enter
the professional
tournaments, and
these professional tournaments
have big prize money.
You know, this AlphaGo match
had $1 million for the winner,
but that was an extreme case.
There is this one big tournament
going on called Ing Cup,
and that has $400,000
for the first place.
And we have Samsung Cup, and
LG Cup, MLily Cup-- these all
have $300,000 for the winner.
And these are
international tournaments.
Some domestic
tournaments inside Korea,
I would have more like
$50,000, or $40,000.
But, in any case, if you are
about, like, top 50 in Korea,
then you can make a
decent living income
just by playing in tournaments.
But if you are past the prime,
or you are not in top 50,
then you can also teach Go.
Or you could commentate on TV.
We have this Baduk TV that
only broadcasts Go programs.
And you could be working
for Go-related companies.
You could write Go books.
So there are many other
things that you can do.
Another thing about
professional players in Korea
is that you get to have a voice,
especially inside the KBA.
So KBA makes, all day,
policy decisions, and then
they make directions
for development.
And if you are a Go lover,
and you have many ideas,
and you go to the KBA, they
are probably not going to care.
But if you are a
professional player,
and you have some ideas about
their policies or direction,
you can directly knock on the
door of this vice chairman,
the highest person in the KBA.
And then the vice chairman
would invite you to come in,
and he will listen, because
you are a professional player.
And other than this, if you are
a professional player in Korea,
you meet someone-- and,
say, they would ask you,
what do you do?
And then you say, oh, I'm
a professional player.
And then the first thing
they would say is, wow,
you must be smart.
So that's what you get in Korea.
And also, if you are single, and
this is the elder Go friends--
they could start, you know, I
have this son in med school.
[LAUGHTER]
So, yeah.
That's the professional players.
And, you know, that was the
professional word as we know.
But recently, there was this
thing that happened-- AlphaGo.
So AlphaGo is a computer
program with general artificial
intelligence.
And I'm sure you are
very eager to hear more.
I'm going to skip all the
rest of the technical side,
just to save time,
not because I don't
understand the algorithms.
[LAUGHTER]
So let's talk about the
AlphaGo match in Seoul.
It was in March, just
about 1 1/2 months ago.
My involvement in
the AlphaGo match
started last year,
about November,
when DeepMind reached out
to me through the British Go
Association.
They had just defeated
Fan Hui, and then they
wanted to have a
higher level challenge.
And because they didn't have any
experience in organizing a Go
event with top Asian pros,
they had so many questions.
So I told them about usual
practices, the top players'
expectations, and when
would be a good time,
where would be a good location.
And then, when they
decided to invite
Lee Sedol 9-dan for
the five-game match
and to have it in
Seoul, I volunteered
to be the messenger.
And I told them, oh,
I can talk to the KBA,
because I am very
close with them.
And at the time,
I thought that it
would be really fun to
watch this game happening.
At first, I thought
there was no way
that AlphaGo could
defeat Lee Sedol 9-dan,
but soon enough, I learned
that it was extremely strong.
And then I still doubted that
it could defeat Lee Sedol,
but I thought it
would be very, very
exciting to watch them play.
And then I thought--
I am from the IGF.
This is the work for
DeepMind and the KBA.
I'm going to
deliver the message,
and then sit back
and enjoy the game.
But that's not what happened,
because my role expanded
one-by-one, and then I
was doing these roles.
It was not like I
volunteered for all of this,
but more like I had a
very unique position
that I could help in
all of these roles.
So I was a professional
player, and then I
had a personal relation
with Lee Sedol 9-dan.
I was close with KBA
leaders, because they
come to the IGF meetings.
And I was also close
with KBA staff members.
In KBA, there are about 50
full-time staff members.
And I was very close with
them, because my office is also
inside the KBA building.
And for almost three years, I
was working there and having
lunch with them everyday.
So I was involved
from the beginning-- I
had a very good understanding.
And also, KBA and DeepMind
had some language barriers.
They didn't speak each
other's language very well.
So I was there and in-between,
and I could connect everyone.
So I ended up doing
so many roles.
And then during
this AlphaGo match,
I don't think I was ever
busier than that time.
My phone was literally
ringing all day.
And the commentator would
call me, and I am on the way,
and then a KBA colleague calls
me, and he needs me right away.
And there is this
DeepMind looking
for me, like, pinging me.
And there's journalists grabbing
me-- I have some questions.
So it was, like, amazingly busy.
So I have some
pictures over here.
This first picture-- this
is from my best friend,
and she didn't know
that I was working.
She suddenly sent me this
picture, and said, Hajin,
I saw you on TV.
So I was like, oh.
And then she said, Dennis
looks like your brother.
I hope that was a compliment.
[LAUGHTER]
So this is the picture.
And then this is from
the playing venue.
One of the roles I took was
Le Sedol 9-dan's translator,
so I got to talk with Dennis.
And then also when
Eric Schmidt and Sergey
Brin met with Le Sedol 9-dan,
I was there to translate.
I was very impressed by
how respectful they were.
I thought that was
really true leadership.
And then I was emcee of the
pre-match press briefing,
and press conference,
and the awards ceremony.
It was my first time
to do emcee in front
of, like, hundreds of cameras.
And generally, I
would get nervous,
just as I'm nervous right now.
But at the time,
I was so busy, I
didn't have the
mind to be nervous.
So I wouldn't remember
what I did after that.
So these are some pictures.
And then getting into the match.
KBA had two main goals,
and then two minor goals.
The two main goals--
the first one
was to have the match as fair
as possible, and problem-free.
Because one player was not
human for the first time,
we had to make sure about
all the possible problems.
And then we wanted to make sure
that none of the two players
would have something to
complain after the match.
And luckily, I think we
managed that very well,
so there were no complaints.
And then, the second goal was
to have as much exposure as
possible for Go.
And then, two minor
goals-- the first one
was to build some good
relationship with DeepMind.
We thought that this may not
be the last one we do together.
There could be some
other future projects,
so we wanted to work with
them, with a trust base,
and build a really
good relationship.
Another goal was to
return some favors
to the journalists or
the Go sponsors who've
been helping the Korean Go
community for a long time.
We didn't get to have this
good position very often.
But during this match,
it was so popular,
and everyone wanted
to enter the site.
And then KBA, for
the first time,
had this higher status-- to
give some favors to people,
because they all wanted to come.
So KBA could exercise some
of its status to let them in.
And I think many of
them were very happy
that they could be there.
It was a historical event.
And at the end of
the match, I think
the KBA leaders were very
satisfied with the results.
And as a bonus, we had really,
really good outreach impact.
So all together, we had
280 million viewers.
Over 35,000 articles published--
and these 35,000 articles
include all the headline
news you can imagine.
There was CNN, and BBC, "Wall
Street Journal," "New York
Times," and "The New Yorker."
And there were over 300
journalists on-site.
We had AlphaGo and Lee Sedol
on the top 10 of Twitter trend
worldwide-- it was amazing.
And then inside Korea,
the AlphaGo news
was making the front
page almost everyday.
And all together, we had over
2,000 articles published.
And usually, in
Korea, we would say,
one small article
in the newspaper
would be worth about
$1,000, if you calculate.
So it was a really huge
success-- more successful
than we had hoped for.
And this is all the
TV channels in Korea
that broadcast it live.
So KBS, NBC and SBS are the top
three TV channels in Korea--
they all live broadcasted.
And there were
other TV channels,
and the viewership was so high.
I asked someone from the
broadcasting industry,
and he told me
that you could say
that this interest was higher
than soccer World Cup A match.
And, you know, soccer is
very popular in Korea.
So that was just amazing.
It was surreal.
So it was a huge success.
And then this is a picture from
the Korean commentary room.
You can see that there were
so many people over there.
So all together, we
had a huge success.
And then, as a
result of this event,
AlphaGo became the symbol
of artificial intelligence.
Still, in Korea, many
people use AlphaGo
as a metaphor for anything
artificial intelligence.
And Lee Sedol 9-dan
also became a huge star.
He already appeared
on two TV commercials,
and I heard there
were more to come.
And Go also became very popular.
So overall, we had very good
results than we could imagine.
So this was the AlphaGo match,
and it has been about 1 1/2
months since the AlphaGo match.
And we are still
seeing the interest
that is from the AlphaGo
match, but it's slowly fading.
But still, there is this
fundamental question
that people have in their mind.
So now that the computer,
or AlphaGo, is so strong,
it's possibly a lot stronger
than any professional players,
especially if it's
still improving.
If that is true, is it
still worth it for people
to dedicate their lives
to master these Go skills?
What about the professional
Go players that
already dedicated their lives?
And there was this "New
Yorker" article titled,
In the Age of Google DeepMind,
do they still have the future--
the Go prodigies of Asia?
This article describes the life
of the young prodigies in Asia.
And then actually, Dawn, the
writer of this article-- she
interviewed me three
times over Skype,
so she quoted me many
times in this article.
So this article basically
doesn't answer the question,
but it lays out the situation--
like, this is the situation.
And no one knows, you know--
the future, we can't tell.
But in my mind, if you
ask me, is it still worth
pursuing your career as
a professional Go player?
My answer is yes,
and for two reasons.
The first one is
that I think Go is
more of a mind sport than work.
If professional Go players' work
was to generate better-- like,
sitting at the
office, then AlphaGo
could replace all of them.
But in my mind, they are more
of the athletes in sport.
Go is a mind sport.
And people enjoy
watching sports,
not because machines
can't do better than them,
but because they are inspired
by these athletes who
are pushing their limits.
They are developing
their skills,
and that is a story-- it's
a valuable story, I think.
Another thing is that I think Go
skills are transferable skills.
And there were many
research studies
that shows how learning Go
can help children to develop
responsibilities,
problem-solving skills,
behavioral education.
So I believe training in Go
is as valuable as training
in other sports.
So in that sense, I believe
that it's still worth it.
And then also, we have to
think about future changes.
Now that AlphaGo
is out there, it
could be from DeepMind,
or someone else,
that technical changes would
come to the Go industry.
I don't know when
that would be, but it
will happen, because
AlphaGo inspired
a lot of software engineers.
And already, some companies
in China, or in Korea,
or everywhere in the
world, they are already
working on second
or third AlphaGo.
And it will be probably
only a matter of time
that they reach the
top professional level.
So how will this
technical development
change the Go system
or Go community?
At the moment, we have
this ecosystem in Go.
We have Go fans, the
hobby players who
watch professional
games, and pay
for the lessons, who
buy Go books and then
play with their
friends or play online.
Because we have
these Go fans, we
have professional tournaments.
And also because
we have Go fans,
we have Go lessons-- this
includes all the Go books,
Go lessons, and Go
schools, et cetera.
And professional
tournaments and Go
lessons-- they require
elite players--
the professional
players, Go prodigy,
or the strong amateur players
whose life depends on their Go
teaching classes and all.
So if you don't have
any of these elements,
the ecosystem of Go
would lose its balance.
For example, if we don't
have elite players,
the professional tournaments
wouldn't be as interesting.
If they were no Go books,
or quality Go classes,
Go teachers, it would be
very difficult to have
the elite players
or the Go fans.
One thing about Go--
Go tournaments and Go
infrastructure--
is that in order
to enjoy Go-- top
players' Go games--
you need to be a
Go player yourself.
For other sports like soccer,
or basketball, or baseball,
you don't have to be
a player yourself.
But in Go, if you
are just a beginner,
you could still enjoy with
the commentary of, like, very
detailed explanations,
but still, you
will be missing a lot.
If you are a strong
Go player, then you
can enjoy the game a lot better.
So that's why this is
very important in order
to maintain the Go system.
So when there is this new
technology that comes in,
some part of the ecosystem
can lose its power,
and that can be a little
destructive for the system.
So what I'm hoping to see in the
future is balanced development.
So we take the ecosystem
of Go, and let's imagine
there is these individual
tools where these Go fans can
play AlphaGo, for example.
They can access in their
home, and they can play.
This could be very fun and
very interesting-- so much so
that they won't be as
interested in watching
other professional players'
games, or pay for other lessons
or buy Go books.
If that happens, then it can
damage other Go teachers'
lives, or we can lose
some Go sponsors.
That will be hard.
So in order to
maintain the balance,
I think we would also need
some spectator's tools,
or commentator's
tools, in order to make
watching professional
games more enjoyable.
Also, we would need some
kind of teachers' tools,
so that we can also provide
as interesting Go lessons
or Go books.
And when we have
all of these, we
would have naturally higher
expectations for elite players.
So we can have also
some training tools
for having the elite players.
If we can have
all this together,
we can strengthen each part,
and then, all together,
have a stronger Go
industry than ever.
And this is not the first
time that technology
help some industry-- we've
seen this in all other areas.
It's just that it
came at last in Go.
We didn't think it was
possible, but it happened.
And if we can maintain
this balance of all areas,
I think it could be a lot
better for Go in the future.
So that's about I
think about the future,
and that was about AlphaGo.
And that's all I
prepared for today.
And I would be happy to
answer some of your questions.
[APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: We
have a Dory set up,
so I'm going to switch to Dory.
If anybody wants to ask a
live question while I do that,
that would be great.
Actually, I'm going to abuse
my position here, and ask
you the first question.
So I will ask you
about an anecdote which
you relayed in one of
your YouTube videos,
which was-- did you know
what an NDA was before this?
And how did you explain
that to Lee Sedol?
HAJIN LEE: Ah.
I knew what an NDA was.
And then it wasn't difficult
to explain to Lee Sedol 9-dan,
because I just told him,
you can't tell about it.
[LAUGHTER]
So what I did was that I gave
him the invitation from Google
DeepMind, and that had
all the important details,
like the dates,
and the location,
and the prize money,
and the match format,
which was a five-game match.
It didn't have the sponsor
name, or the opponent name.
And then he said, I can't accept
unless I know the opponent.
So I told him, I can tell
you the opponent name
only if you sign the NDA.
And then he said, so,
I can't talk about it?
So I said, no, you can't.
And then he said, OK.
And then he signed the NDA.
And then I told him about
that-- AlphaGo-- yes.
MALE SPEAKER: And
was he surprised?
HAJIN LEE: He was
very surprised.
[LAUGHTER]
MALE SPEAKER: Us, too.
HAJIN LEE: Yes.
MALE SPEAKER: Sorry.
So I'm going to read these.
So we have a Dory.
I'm going to take the first
couple questions from this,
and then we'll ask
some live questions.
So how do classic Go games
compare to modern play?
And can you see obvious
mistakes in the classic era
players-- Shuei,
Dosaku-- outside
of new joseki innovations?
And which era's games
are the most worth
studying for amateurs?
That's about three
questions there.
HAJIN LEE: Wow.
So, the classical games are very
different from modern games,
mainly because they didn't have
this system called "komi"--
that's like compensation
points for white,
because black plays first.
So in the olden times,
instead of trying
to balance out by giving
some points to white
for playing later, they
would just do two games.
So two players would play,
once with black, and once
with white.
And there is this legendary
player who was so strong,
and he never lost with black.
So the saying is that when
someone asked, how did you do?
And he would answer, I was
black, and that meant he won.
So that's why the games
were very different.
And then, as time
passed, we developed
many more opening theories
and endgame theories.
So it is generally agreed
among professional players
that we are stronger
than before.
But for amateur players,
the classic games
are still worth studying,
because they were still
very strong, and they
had a very deep reading.
Another thing was that they
would spend a lot of time
for each move.
These days, we finish one
game at least in a day.
The longer games
take, like, 10 hours,
but still, it wouldn't
take more than one day.
In Japan, still,
there are some title
matches that would last
two days, but that's all.
In the olden times, the
games would take months,
because they would
think until they decide.
And they would take long breaks.
So the game records are
actually quite good,
so you can still study.
But it will be difficult to use
the same moves in modern games,
because of the komi, and then
different playing styles.
Which era's games-- I'm
not sure about that one.
MALE SPEAKER: I'll
just comment--
Shusaku, who was the player
who would take black,
would win-- he was a
19th-century Japanese player.
There's a very good book in
English called "Invincible."
I'm not sure if it's
still available,
but that was, I think, still
one of the best English books
in English about Go.
And it's a complete commentary
on most of his games.
So if you are looking for a
very expensive book to buy,
that would be it.
[LAUGHTER]
Excellent choice.
AUDIENCE: You can get it
pretty cheap on [INAUDIBLE].
MALE SPEAKER: Oh, really?
AUDIENCE: Or Go Books.
MALE SPEAKER: Oh, OK.
Is there a question
from the audience?
HAJIN LEE: Yes.
AUDIENCE: I know the
AGA has been trying
to build an American
professional system, which I'm
all in favor of, but
then I take the thought
of-- to a Westerner, the idea of
sending your six-year-old child
to go live with
somebody else in order
to become a professional board
game player is very strange.
Do you think that we have
that cultural problem
of just not being used to
the kind of thing it takes
to become that level of pro?
HAJIN LEE: That's right.
It will be very difficult to
reach the Asian top pro level
without that kind of
intensive training,
but I think it is possible,
if you have a strong Go
teacher living nearby.
It doesn't have to be, like,
separating from your parents,
if you have the
teacher right there.
So that could be one thing.
Another thing is that
now we have the internet.
When I was 9 years old, we
didn't have strong internet.
And there were no strong players
to play, like, very freely.
So with this aid of technology
and maybe some strong teachers'
presence, I think, the American
students-- they could also
get very strong.
MALE SPEAKER: The
other thing is,
it's not that different--
like, women's gymnastics,
for example, they start studying
and training at that age,
right?
I don't know that they
move in with their teacher,
but it's often pretty intense.
And people have been known to
move cross-country to play,
you know, to study with a coach.
AUDIENCE: Yeah. [INAUDIBLE].
MALE SPEAKER:
Athletics is, I think,
what you should compare it to.
I'm going to take one
more from up here.
HAJIN LEE: Oh, yes.
MALE SPEAKER: If I can get
it to-- oh, look at that.
So, have you seen any pros
copying AlphaGo moves or style?
HAJIN LEE: So, they have
been saying on Facebook
that Lee Sedol 9-dan's moves
were somehow resemblant AlphaGo
moves.
And then someone
actually asked him
if he was trying to
copy AlphaGo's style.
And he said, I wasn't
consciously trying to copy,
but I am trying to
think differently.
And the main thing he
said was that before, he
had some intuitive moves that
came from his experiences,
but now he tries to
rely on 100% reading.
So one thing we were
amazed by AlphaGo
was that it would play a
move that we would never
think about.
And that was because
I think AlphaGo
didn't have any preconceptions.
And that was just an
amazing experience.
MALE SPEAKER: Comments?
Andrew?
AUDIENCE: During the
AlphaGo match week,
I think a lot of players,
as the week went on,
became very excited by the
idea that, more quickly than we
thought, we would see
the next level of Go,
because AlphaGo would
force us into it,
or simply show us what it was.
Before AlphaGo, would you
say that most professional Go
players, somewhere in
the back of their mind,
thought, we haven't
reached ideal Go playing?
That there is a next level--
we just don't know what it is?
Was that the opinion,
do you think?
HAJIN LEE: Right.
So before AlphaGo,
professor players
did know that there
was a higher level,
but they thought
the higher level,
the margin of that difference
was very narrow-- very, very,
very narrow, that you
could study for, like,
another 15 years, and
there is no guarantee
that you would get
this much stronger.
But after AlphaGo, what
professional players realized
was that it wasn't that narrow.
There was this whole lot
of different level of Go,
and that was very
inspiring for all pros.
MALE SPEAKER: Oh, there we go.
HAJIN LEE: That one--
I am not sure what
it means by "mistakes,"
because AlphaGo
has very different ideas of best
moves from we human players.
So human players, because
we can't read all the way
throughout the end, we
just take maybe about up
to five or 10 or 15
moves, and then try
to have maximum advance
after that sequence.
But in the case of
AlphaGo, AlphaGo
would look at the
end of the game,
and then make sure that
AlphaGo has the highest
probability of winning.
And in winning, how
many points wouldn't
matter, whether it's like
half points win, or like
10 points win.
AlphaGo only cares
about winning.
So, some moves of
AlphaGo, we could
feel like that was a mistake.
But then in AlphaGo's system,
it wouldn't be mistake.
So I think it's
very hard to say.
AUDIENCE: But the response
to the wedge in game four--
AlphaGo missed.
HAJIN LEE: That's right.
That was a clear mistake-- yes.
The fourth game that Lee Sedol
9-dan won-- and the wedge,
it's called "The
Move," "God's Move"--
that actually didn't work, if
AlphaGo responded in the right
way.
But the thing was that AlphaGo
didn't predict the move.
And I think Dennis
said that AlphaGo
thought the chance of white
playing there was 1:10,000.
And in Go board, there were
only about 200 spots to play.
So it was a very strange
move in AlphaGo's opinion.
And AlphaGo thought it
could just now answer.
So that was a mistake.
Right.
MALE SPEAKER: We're going
to go to the next one.
So this is-- Andrew Jackson
asked this question.
HAJIN LEE: Ah.
That's a very, very
difficult question.
And then I am afraid that
after answering something,
I would regret later.
[LAUGHTER]
So naturally, I would
say, can I come back
with the answer in one day?
But right in my
mind, I would say,
the best thing would be an
international Go tournament
for the top
professional players.
It would be even better if
the winner of the tournament
could play AlphaGo.
That would be like a
big exhibition match.
That would be awesome, I think.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so we've
had, I guess, over 10 years
now to kind of see what happened
with chess, with Deep Blue.
And it seems like,
I mean, people still
sort of play chess.
And top grandmasters use strong
computer programs, and still
kind of the competitions among
the strong computer programs.
So do you feel like Go will have
kind of a similar experience
to chess?
Do you think it'll react to
computers kind of the same way
that chess did?
HAJIN LEE: Yes, I think
that's absolutely possible.
Actually, after
the AlphaGo match,
we had a small party
among the organizers.
And I was talking with
these Google people,
and we were lightly
joking about the future.
And then they
mentioned Facebook.
And they said that if AlphaGo
played the Facebook computer
artificial intelligence
in the future,
they would play, like, a
million games in half an hour.
[LAUGHTER]
But that was obviously a joke.
But, you know, Lee Sedol 9-dan,
he would spend a lot of time
thinking-- in the
future, I think
it is possible that computers
would play each other.
And then also, I
heard in chess, it's
very interesting to see the
competition between human plus
machine, versus
just machine alone.
That could be also an
interesting format, I think.
Yes.
There is a question over there.
AUDIENCE: So you mentioned that
one of the goals of the AlphaGo
match was having a good
relationship with Google
DeepMind.
So I wonder if you can share
some short-term or long-term
plans for some events
like AlphaGo match?
HAJIN LEE: Yes.
At the moment, we don't have any
specific plans with DeepMind.
We will have to see.
So during the AlphaGo match,
DeepMind told us, KBA,
that they haven't planned
much of the future yet,
because they wanted to see
how the result comes out.
And then they would
analyze, and then they
would decide what's
the next move.
And I think they are still
considering different options.
Yes.
So AlphaGo's-- when the match--
was arranged-- was your-- Ah,
OK.
So before the match
against Lee Sedol
9-dan, I thought
AlphaGo was very strong.
I knew that AlphaGo was strong.
And I also knew that the
games against Fan Hui
didn't show 100%
of its strength,
partially because
AlphaGo was winning.
And when AlphaGo
is winning, AlphaGo
doesn't play its
strongest moves.
It just plays safe moves.
Another thing was
that DeepMind publicly
shared that AlphaGo was still
improving and still training,
and that it will be better by
the time it plays Lee Sedol.
So I knew that it
would be strong,
but I had my doubts
that it would still
defeat Lee Sedol 9-dan.
And I did share with him, but I
think Lee Sedol was very, very
confident.
And even though I told him,
you should be more careful.
But--
[LAUGHTER]
--he didn't take it
seriously enough, I think.
AUDIENCE: Did you ever get
a chance to play AlphaGo?
HAJIN LEE: Um, AlphaGo?
We will talk privately.
[LAUGHTER]
MALE SPEAKER: There we go.
HAJIN LEE: Mm.
Right.
And I think-- is it the
end of the question?
MALE SPEAKER: Oh yeah, you can
see the end of the question
here.
HAJIN LEE: Ah, OK.
Can you go back?
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, hopefully.
HAJIN LEE: I'm a little confused
by the question, because--
MALE SPEAKER: I think
the question is,
who would benefit more from--
HAJIN LEE: Ah, OK.
If it was longer, who
would benefit more?
Both.
I'm not sure who
would benefit more.
If the game was longer,
I would have suffered--
[LAUGHTER]
--because I was so busy.
And then the 300
plus [INAUDIBLE]
would have suffered,
because they
thought it was already so long.
And the commentators.
But the two players would
have enjoyed, I think.
I'm not sure who would
have had more benefits.
MALE SPEAKER: I think, like,
the two-hour time control--
that's a typical [INAUDIBLE]
HAJIN LEE: Yes.
Right.
MALE SPEAKER: --international.
The only people who play
the two-day tournaments
are the Japanese,
so I think it would
be-- if they had played Iyama,
who's the top player in Japan
now-- they're more used to
playing with that time control.
HAJIN LEE: Right.
Yes.
MALE SPEAKER: So you know, it
takes practice, I think, to--
HAJIN LEE: Yes.
Right.
AUDIENCE: I know in the
second or third game,
after AlphaGo made a very
strange move, Lee Sedol,
like, left the room.
Where did he go?
[LAUGHTER]
HAJIN LEE: Yeah.
He went smoking, I think.
Yeah.
So the Four Seasons hotel
that we had this AlphaGo
match-- they organized
a private terrace
for Lee Sedol 9-dan to smoke.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] typical
in a professional match
for one professional to
be smoking [INAUDIBLE]
during the match?
HAJIN LEE: It's not
typical to smoke,
but it is very common to take
a short break to just get
some fresh air, or some walk.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I noted that after
all the games, including
the games that Lee
Sedol 9-dan lost,
he left the playing room
quickly, and went away
for a while, and then came
back for the press conference.
And at the press conference,
he was cheerful and composed.
Can you comment a little bit on
what, for a champion Go player,
winning and losing
publicly is like,
and then composing
yourself after it?
What was going on in that
45 minutes after the game?
And actually, a second
question-- the part
at the end of the game where you
review with your opponent was
missing from this game, because
the opponent wasn't there
to review with.
Is that a very important part
emotionally of a pro's game?
HAJIN LEE: Yes.
The first question--
so Lee Sedol 9-dan
did extremely well in
post-game press conferences
after each game.
And I was very impressed,
because in Go tournaments,
the common practice is that
you only interview the winners.
You leave the losers alone,
because they are already sad.
[LAUGHTER]
But we planned this press
conference after each game,
regardless of the
result, because it
was very important for
all the journalists
to hear what he thought about.
And they also wanted to hear
from the DeepMind developers.
So, at first, I was
a little concerned.
So I told Lee Sedol
9-dan, several times
before he started the game, that
he needed to come to the press
conference after the game.
Because he could also just
disappear and go to his room.
But very impressively,
he not only
came to the press conference,
but he did the interview
so well, that I think this is
a very big reason why Lee Sedol
9-dan became a big
star after the match.
Although he lost, he
still was very-- yeah,
as he said-- he
was still cheerful.
And he would answer very
humbly and genuinely.
So that was a really
good role model
for all the
professional players.
And during the short breaks
between the game and the press
conference, he would
review the game.
So he would talk about
the moves that he played,
or the moves that
AlphaGo played.
After the first game, we
weren't really prepared for him
to review, because he
didn't have the opponent.
And he was actually asking
me a lot of questions.
And it was not direct
questions, but more like I
was alone there with him.
And he was saying,
maybe I should
have done the knight's move.
Should I have wedged over here?
What did you think
about this invasion?
And I was there.
And actually, I was too
busy to see the game,
so I didn't actually
know what to say.
And he kept saying these things.
And I felt terrible.
Because I knew, as a
professional player,
that just talking about
the game makes you feel,
somehow, more relaxed,
because you're still
processing the
result. And especially
after the first game, it must
have been very hard on him,
because he didn't
expect to lose.
But luckily, he did very
well in the press conference.
And then from the
second game, I made sure
that there were some
strong pros that he
could talk about the game.
So when the game was over,
I would bring in one or two
professional players,
and then they
would review for about half
an hour in the play room.
And when the press
conference was getting close,
like in five minutes,
or in 10 minutes,
I would tell them that
it's press conference soon,
and they would move
to the waiting room.
And I'm sure it was
hard, because he couldn't
review with the opponent.
He couldn't review
with [INAUDIBLE].
Although [INAUDIBLE] was a very
good representation of AlphaGo,
he couldn't review on
behalf of AlphaGo, sadly.
But because he
could still review
with his professional
friends, I think
it had a similar
effect in the end.
MALE SPEAKER: I think
there might be [INAUDIBLE].
HAJIN LEE: Right.
MALE SPEAKER: We're running
low on time here, so--
HAJIN LEE: Yeah,
so this question--
it's one of the
fundamental questions
that all pros are
asking themselves.
If AlphaGo can really
teach individual players,
where would professional
players or the Go teachers
go for their income?
And I think the
answer is that they
will have to be as competitive
as AlphaGo tools-- meaning,
they will have to
teach better to attract
the Go players to pay
for their lessons, right?
And for that, I think they will
need something like Alphago.
MALE SPEAKER: We can
take one more question,
and then we'll take a break.
HAJIN LEE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So for
the past two years,
I've been trying to get
more people to play Go,
and I've found out that
getting people to play Go
is kind of like getting people
to become software engineers.
Women tend to not
want to play Go.
There's a huge movement
now to promote diversity
in software engineering,
and I'm wondering,
is there something
similar in Korea
that we can learn from to
promote diversity in Go?
HAJIN LEE: First
of all, in Korea,
we don't have a higher
gender ratio for women.
We have about the same.
We have the same problem, where
only about 10% of Go population
are women.
And also, we also
have been conscious
about this situation
and thinking
that we should do something.
I don't think there
have been major efforts
to actually do promote
Go to women yet,
but I think we are taking
some baby steps toward that.
And we are aware
of the situation.
It's difficult to share
any success story,
because we don't have one yet.
Maybe we can--
AUDIENCE: Do you have any ideas?
HAJIN LEE: --work on it.
Maybe we need more role
models, like some star player
who is a woman-- maybe a
star engineer who is a woman.
And I think these role models
can really inspire young girls
to follow their path.
AUDIENCE: Can I
[INAUDIBLE] this?
HAJIN LEE: Yes.
AUDIENCE: So I started,
me and some of my friends
starting playing because of
"Hikaru no Go," the anime.
And I feel like if there
was a similar anime,
but with a woman player, or
more women players, [INAUDIBLE],
it could probably bring
more women or girls
when I was at that age to play.
And I'd like to say more
role models and just
active [INAUDIBLE].
That's my opinion.
HAJIN LEE: Right, yes.
AUDIENCE: Actually, the
author of that was a woman.
MALE SPEAKER:
Yeah, that's right.
HAJIN LEE: That's right.
Yes.
MALE SPEAKER: We're going
to take a brief break,
and then we're going
to reconvene over
in [INAUDIBLE], which is
a training room in 2000.
And Ms. Lee is going
to play some Go.
HAJIN LEE: All right.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]